Deci ce este Qiskit
Qiskit este un kit de dezvoltare software open source
pentru lucrul cu calculatoare cuantice
la nivelul circuit-urilor
algoritmilor și modulelor de aplicații. Acest SDK
permite oricui să programeze pe calculatoare cuantice reale de pe
laptopul lor. În două linii de cod poți accesa
mai multe sisteme cuantice, de la superconductoare
până la qubit-uri cu ioni captivi. Vrei să emulezi comportamentul unui calculator cuantic?
Schimbă o singură linie de cod
și simulează circuit-urile tale cuantice pe performanța noastră ridicată
simulator. Qiskit este un instrument folosit de zeci de
mii de oameni din toată lumea care încearcă să
construiască viitorul. Fie că ești cercetător, dezvoltator
sau vrei doar să începi
Qiskit are un număr de
funcționalități disponibile pentru nevoile tale
permițând oricui să facă lucruri
precum construirea primului tău circuit cuantic
rularea de algoritmi cuantici cross-domain
și studierea fenomenelor cuantice fundamentale
Poate acum e momentul perfect să te implici și tu
și să găsești toate instrumentele de care ai nevoie
inclusiv calculatoare cuantice reale
și SDK-ul prin Qiskit
și o comunitate care e bucuroasă să te primească
și să răspundă la orice întrebări ai putea avea pe parcurs
Poți începe astăzi
la Qiskit